hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
where we look at how you can model the
successful strategies of famous
entrepreneurs today we're going to look
at the multi-millionaire founder of
American Idol Simon Fuller Simon Fuller
is a British artist manager television
producer and creator of the idol
franchise first seen as Pop Idol in the
UK and over 100 other versions including
American Idol and Canadian Idol Fuller
is a co-creator and executive producer
of the Fox TV reality show so he can
condense and other US and European TV
shows his also or has been the manager
of performers and entertainers including
S Club 7 David and Victoria Beckham Andy
Lennox Andy Murray the Spice Girls Lisa
Marie Presley David Cook
Adam Lambert and others fuller started
his first company 19 entertainment when
he was 25 years old and sold it in 2005
for over 200 million dollars in 2007 he
was named by Time magazine as one of the
hundred most influential people in the
world he is a mystery entrepreneur
behind the scenes who was making
millions and calling the shots while
flying under the radar and here's what
you can learn from his success
so the next question becomes how can you
model the successful strategies of Simon
Fuller here are three action items and
you could put to use in your business
today action avidin umber one put
yourself in your customers shoes as
entrepreneurs we can easily get lost in
our product or service and how great it
is
we can't wait to launch the next version
or introduce a new feature the trouble
is were often creating products for
ourselves and are not focused enough on
our customer will actually want this new
product or service Simon Fuller is a
master at putting himself in his
customers shoes when he came across a
pop group called spice he recognized
that their market was limited young
girls traditionally only buy music from
male singers as they are threatened by
the women to fix this problem he changed
the name to Spice Girls and launched
their girl power theme which made young
girls want to buy their music just as
much as the boys fuller took five young
women turned them into Superstars and
the best-selling girl group of all time
with over 75 million records sold by
puttin himself in his customers shoes
think about your product or service are
you really solving a need for your
customers that nobody else is offering
put yourself in your customers shoes you
can knock their socks off with your next
product launch action item number two
know what you're good at everybody has
strengths and weaknesses the trouble is
as entrepreneurs we tend to try to do
everything even though we're only good
at a few things if you focus your
attention and build your business around
what you're really good at you have a
much higher chance of success and also
have a lot more fun Simon Fuller
strengths is promoting somebody or
something while it's popular and then
dropping it to move on to the next hot
trend no matter how great the artist he
is working on promoting today seems to
be he always has another one waiting in
the wings ready to go when the Spice
Girls dumped him as manager he
immediately began to promote as Club 7
after us Club 7 split he was ready with
S Club juniors in his own words my
business is creating Fame and celebrity
and I'm one of the best in the world I
know it to the finest detail and that's
the beauty of his pop idol American Idol
franchise it doesn't matter how much
real talent or staying power the winners
have because audiences will quickly move
on to listening to next season's
contestants fuller built a bit
compliments what he's best at the
business model works for him instead of
the other way around
think about your own business for a
second do you have to do things you hate
and aren't good at like cold calling to
bring in clients you'll see a huge jump
in your business if you can make the
business model work for you and focus
your energies and what you're really
good at action item number 3 paint a
vision for your customers if you're
trying to sell something new or have a
difficult sales process you should
consider giving your customer a vision
of their future as a part of your pitch
show your customers what their lives
will look like if they work with you let
them imagine a benefits that you can
offer and convince them on an emotional
level that they should become your
client when Simon Fuller wanted to
expand his reach into managing
celebrities he went after one of the
biggest names in the world soccer
superstar David Beckham fullest rolled
Beckham by pampering him at Elton John's
mansion and then given him a six-day
vacation in Provence France Fuller
painted a beautiful picture of what it
would be like working with him and
Beckham couldn't resist he signed up for
fuller services okay so you don't know
Elton John and you can't afford to fly
your clients to France but you can do
the same thing on a smaller scale think
about how you can show your prospects
that working with you will lead them to
a better life don't ignore the emotional
part of the sale and focus only on
tangible facts so remember put yourself
in your customers shoes know what you're
really good at and paint a vision of the
future for your customers I wanted to
end the video today by sharing one of my
favorite true stories about Simon Fuller
how do you come up with a company name
in the mid-1980s with just three years
experience under his belt fuller quit
his job and set off on his own it was a
risky decision the one that paid off
when fuller discovered Paul Hardcastle
Hardcastle had written a song called 19
which centred on the Vietnam war with
Fuller's help the song became a huge hit
and fuller celebrated by naming his new
company 1919 entertainment was
officially launched in 1985
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the masters I hope
you enjoyed and I'd love to hear your
thoughts if you want to leave a comment
below this video stay tuned for the next
episode